are just rubbish I think it's some sort
of like fish spread or something but
it's oh can I swear on this go ahead
awesome
that is so bad
[Music]
hello I am WWE Superstar Seth freaking
Rollins and you are watching snack Wars
on sport Bible today we are pitting UK
snacks against U.S snacks in preparation
for WWE's money in the bank premium live
event what is it called a clush a clash
I've never heard of that in my life all
right here we go
oh yeah now we're speaking my language
ah a little coffee coffee let's go baby
on my right we've got some Starbucks
here I'm just gonna pop the lid because
I don't really like sipping through that
thing I don't trust it I got a nice
white fit on here today I do not want to
get any coffee on that full disclosure I
own my own coffee shop so
Starbucks for me is a absolute Last
Resort when it comes to coffee it's bad
coffee straight up so here we go here we
go let's see
yeah man it tastes like a bottom of an
ashtray that's garbage uh what is this
high protein beef paste why is there
beef taste with the coffee what what am
I supposed to do with this so
traditionally at football matches or
soccer matches that would be served as a
drink oh this is not coffee this is
liquid beef paste
[Laughter]
that's delicious
that is nice that tastes like a nice
bone broth that's fantastic
that's wonderful like that that is like
a nice soup you know that's good I get
it in in good conscience great a garbage
cup of this coffee over this delicious
beef broth so nutritious and delicious
point for the broth wow I was expecting
that to taste like I will say this is
nice this is like going to a really
fancy restaurant it's all like Gourmet
Sandwiches let's see here I'm gonna
start with this nonsense uh only because
I know this is gonna be delicious okay
now
wow
okay we got layers here
oh that looks like baby poop what is the
smell of that what is this
oh my God no way
oh it also smells like baby poop what is
this okay I'll put it on this cracker
I'm gonna spread it on this cracker this
smells
like it came straight out of the bottom
of a dumpster this cannot be a food this
has got to be like a joke of some sort
[Laughter]
oh
no no God yeah
okay all right according to the PB and
Jack oh my God just rubbish I think it's
some sort of like fish spread or
something but it's oh can I swear on
this go ahead
awesome
that is so bad so is it a fish is the
anchovy paste yes oh why why
on that
terrible
oh okay here we go first of all
screw this crap right here I can't
endorse anything Logan Paul related or
KSI related so uh you know we can
probably just put that aside for a
minute we'll get back to that
um and then this ah fermented dandelion
and Burdock drink with herbal extracts
exquisitely crafted we'll see about that
it's nice and cold I'm gonna start here
I'm gonna go with this thing a little is
there I don't have a little carbonation
it feels
I like that okay there's a little bit of
carbonation in there
oh yeah
it's a little floral like a little
dandelion I don't know what the Burdock
is but uh this is this is good I'm going
to be reluctant in taking some sips of
this in case you're not familiar I
wrestled Logan Paul at WrestleMania this
year and him and his buddy KSI uh tried
to sneak a win on me but I thwarted them
and uh I was Victorious
so uh maybe I shouldn't hate the ice pop
so much we'll see
oh yeah that's good
oh my God I hate that I hate it I hate
the way it makes me feel inside
oh but it's just it's good it's a good
drink damn it
point to the pie you owe me Logan that's
what we're doing here okay all right
okay yeah a little KFC baby and then uh
this thing again wrapped in paper that
seems to be a theme here all right I'll
start with what I know delicious uh
crispy probably original recipe here
Kentucky Fried Chicken I know what this
is gonna taste like and I'm happy about
it original recipe the whole night
oh come on
so good we have another
pastry type thing you guys love your
pastries over here man I just stuff
everything in a pie crust and call it a
food I'm just gonna go
got baked beans in a pie pocket
why would you do this am I mad at it
it's pretty good the pie crust really
does a lot so that is a sausage bean and
cheese melt there's sausage in here I
know sausage in here you're lying man
I mean unless it's just like pureed
sausage it's very good the pie crust
nice and Flaky the inside is interesting
I think I'm going I'm going KFC on this
one it's delicious it's fantastic
there's no way you can pick this bean
pie over this delicious chicken leg
there's no way
yeah you know what I mean the skin alone
is better than the bean pie so I'm going
KFC on this one all the way all right
here we go bomb yes thank God we got
chocolate we got chocolate we got the
Cadbury bar we got the Hershey Kisses
let's go you love A kiss you love it
it's classic it's just delicious comes
in a bunch of different flavors I
believe this is just a straight
straight delicious milk chocolate and a
nice little bite size here I'm a big fan
of the uh the single serving chocolate
I love it
yeah that's fantastic I mean it's just
local now for what you guys have put me
through so far I need that not bad at
all and this is the Cadbury dairy milk
the packaging is exquisite this looks
like some Willy Wonka you know what I
mean this I mean you want this in your
life like I feel like there's gonna be a
Golden Ticket inside this bar
like that I want that when I buy my
chocolate it feels special
break a little boy
yeah I mean it's just top level it's
just top tier that that's a milk
chocolate that's fine but and I've
always felt this way I've been coming to
the UK for close to 20 years now I've
always felt this way the the chocolate
over here
Copper
Point to the uh the bar here that's a
winner that's so good I might have
another bite the winner was the US
snacks oh
America
this might be the best appearance I've
ever done
it's fun for the show I believe Logan
Paul's big fan of the Prime
I have noticed that Logan holding primes
a lot I've noticed Logan drinking primes
a lot
just when I'm looking but that has been
something that I have noticed